my name is James honda I'm president in
health policy institute in Japan I think
that India is already amazing are
destined to you super pod I think one of
the things which were successfully I can
be there what is the university but also
the demographic must trust agreement
from the top of the China which is aging
almost as much as I'm not any ideas it's
going to be a tremendous saw the graphic
dividend for India especially little
Club youth their 2nd take sensei look
likely people not just middle-market
increase my motor services in the room I
possible so that i really am the
experimental gana or creating an
immediate actions for both get rolled
out sigh and different that Indian
system song thank you
thank you